♪ ♪ ♪
- Bonjour, vous pouvez
vous asseoir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ah, mon Dieu! On voit bien que
nais pas Roger, toi.
Quand il dit non, c'est non!
♪ ♪ ♪- La g- La g- La g- La g- .
C'est pas une raisonpour se fai!
(cris)
- C'est des films d'abord
mais des films dans lesquels
il y a un certain merveill
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ L♪ L♪ L♪ L♪ La belle inconnue♪
seule seule seule seule seule s♪
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ D'une grue géante avez laquai♪
♪ Dans un graans un graans un gl
de projecteurs et de poussière
et de charbon ♪
(applaudissement
bonsoir et bienvenue
au JaÉtoiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ça peut-tu rs
de la voirie, ça? Passer
la jou deux pancartes
qui disent "Ralentir, travaux".
(rires)
♪ ♪ ♪
ours le meilleur
de soi-même et des autres.
toujours déçu,
n'est-ce pas?
'est parfait, c'est ça.
C'est naturel, c'est la vie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Speak White. De Westminster
à Washington, relayez-vous.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pierre Reid.
♪ Edelweiss, Edelweiss ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- M. Plummer est néà Montréal, e
vous avez étudié à Montréal.
- Oui... Compagnie amateur
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ Quand les hommes
vivront d'amour ♪
♪ Il n'y aura plus de misère ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
- À partir du moment où on est
capa l'on
vient, on est capable de savoir
beaucoup mieux où on va.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les mots avaient pour moi une
énorme importance. La sono
de ces mots-là me plaisait.
- Dans ma vie, j'ai rencontré
tellement de gens, tellement
de monde. Chaque personne
m'a enrichi.
♪ ♪ ♪